This episode is one in a four-part series that we're calling the future of dot dot dot. I like to say the dot dot dots. We'll be exploring how changes are the way we live, learn, work, and play, may shape our health and well-being in years to come. Thanks to the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation for supporting this episode. The Robert Wood Johnson Foundation is committed to improving health and health equity in the United States. Learn more about them at rwjf.org. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. And today I'm going to introduce you to my new least favorite word. Resimershul. Here with a definition is producer Chris Perrupe. Resimershul, an adjective referring to a kind of office furniture. It's an awkward mashup of residential and commercial.
本期节目是我们称之为“……的未来”四集系列节目中的一集。我喜欢称之为“点点点”系列。我们将探讨我们生活、学习、游玩和工作方式的变化，将如何塑造我们未来的健康和福祉。感谢罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会对本期节目的支持。罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会致力于改善美国的健康状况和健康公平。访问 rwjf.org 了解更多关于他们的信息。这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。今天我将向大家介绍我的新“最讨厌的词”。Resimershul（住宅式商业）。制作人克里斯·佩鲁佩将为我们提供定义。Resimershul，一个指代某种办公家具的形容词。它是 residential（住宅的）和 commercial（商业的）两个词笨拙的结合。
Basically, Resa Merchal furniture is designed for the workplace, but feels like it belongs in a living room, so think plush comfy couches and coffee tables. And right now, it is all the rage. Now Resa Merchal design has been a pretty hot topic in the industry for the last, let's say, three or four years or so. It's this idea of creating a more home-like atmosphere in a commercial setting. You don't feel a hard side on any of this chair
基本上，Resimershul 家具是为工作场所设计的，但感觉像是属于起居室的，比如毛绒舒适的沙发和咖啡桌。现在，它正大行其道。现在 Resimershul 设计在过去三年或四年左右的时间里一直是业内相当热门的话题。这就是在商业环境中营造更多家庭氛围的想法。无论你以什么姿势坐在这把椅子上
no matter how you're sitting in it. Awesome. A holistic standpoint, we were able to consider comfort into this chair. So why are we getting pitched these comfy wonder chairs for the office? Well, now offices have to compete with everywhere else. Remote work has been on the rise for a couple of years, and the Bureau of Labor Statistics says 35% of American workers were at home in the early days of the pandemic. That's who
你都不会觉得这把椅子的任何一侧很硬。太棒了。从整体的角度来看，我们能够将舒适度融入这把椅子中。那么，为什么办公室要向我们推销这些舒适的神奇椅子呢？嗯，现在办公室必须与其他所有地方竞争。远程办公已经兴行了几年，美国劳工统计局表示，在大流行初期，35% 的美国工人是在家里工作的。这就是我们
we're talking about on the show today. And I have to acknowledge these are the luckiest workers, the people who got to stay home through the worst of COVID. But many of these people, they aren't thrilled about the idea of going back to a physical office. A Gallup survey found that 30% of office workers never want to go back.
今天要在节目中讨论的人。我必须承认，这些是最幸运的工人，是在新冠疫情最严重的时候能够呆在家里的那些人。但这些人中的许多人，对于回到实体办公室的想法并不感到兴奋。盖洛普的一项调查发现，30% 的办公室职员永远不想回去。
Another 60% say they want to stay on a hybrid model, only going to the office a few days a week. A different study found more than half of middle-income workers were thinking about switching jobs and that remote flexibility was a big part of their decision. Those numbers make it clear the office is at this inflection point. And that's why it makes a lot of sense office designers are promising a lot right now. They're promising this office of the future that's more comfortable and more pleasant and basically anything to make us go back. This is not the first time that designers have
另外 60% 的人表示他们希望保持混合办公模式，每周只去办公室几天。另一项研究发现，超过一半的中等收入员工正在考虑换工作，而远程灵活性是他们决定中的很大一部分。这些数字清楚地表明，办公室正处于这个拐点。这就是为什么办公室设计人员现在承诺了很多，这是非常合乎情理的。他们承诺提供一个更舒适、更令人愉快的未来办公室，基本上可以用任何东西来让我们回去。这并不是设计人员第一次
tried to fix the existential malaise of office workers with furniture. In fact, back in the 1960s, we had a lot of the same problems. White-color workers weren't happy. They didn't feel inspired or satisfied by the office, and designers pitched a suite of new furniture that promised to revolutionize their work. Unfortunately, it didn't quite go according to plan. In the early days, office workers were a small part of the workforce, and offices were
试图用家具来解决办公室职员的存在主义 malaise（精神不振）。事实上，早在 20 世纪 60 年代，我们就遇到了很多相同的问题。白领工人很不高兴。他们没有从办公室获得灵感或满足感，设计人员推出了一套承诺彻底改变他们工作的新家具。不幸的是，事情并没有完全按计划进行。在早期，办公室职员只是劳动力的一小部分，办公室
smaller too. Think a couple of clerks sitting in a room with roll-top desks and heavy wooden chairs. But then came multinational corporations, and paperwork, and time-priders, and iron frames for buildings and elevators. Business became big business, and the office went through its first major shift. By 1960, office workers represented one-third of the American workforce, and they had moved into a new fleet of gleaming downtown skyscrapers. It was largely corridor offices you had executive and managerial offices all around the edges,
也更小。想想几个职员坐在一个房间里，用着卷顶桌和沉重的木椅。但随后跨国公司、文书工作、计时员、建筑物的铁框架和电梯出现了。商业变成了大生意，办公室经历了第一次重大转变。到 1960 年，办公室职员占美国劳动力的三分之一，他们搬进了市中心崭新的闪闪发光的高层摩天大楼。这主要是走廊式办公室，四周都是行政和管理人员办公室，
and then in the middle of the office space, a kind of sea of desks. That's the Kills of All. He's a Pennsylvania State Senator, which, okay, sure, big deal, but for our purposes, he's important because a couple of years ago, he wrote a definitive history of the office called CUBE. And he says, the post-war office had very little privacy and a lot of noise. They sounded to a lot of people like factories.
而在办公空间的中间，则是一片办公桌的海洋。那是基尔斯·奥尔。他是宾夕法尼亚州参议员，好吧，当然，这没什么大不了的，但对我们而言，他很重要，因为几年前，他写了一本关于办公室的权威历史书，名为《CUBE》（立方体）。他说，战后的办公室几乎没有隐私，而且有很多噪音。在很多人听来，它们就像工厂。
This is because there was constant typing going on. There was constant click and word of accounting machines. And this all took place in the center of American offices in these typing and accounting pools. Hey, what gives about you? You're getting promoted? Or getting fired? You're going to make a small wage? Yeah.
这是因为不断有人在打字。不断有会计机器的咔哒声和嗡嗡声。这一切都发生在美式办公室中心的这些打字和会计池中。嘿，你这是怎么了？你要升职了？还是被解雇了？你要拿一份微薄的工资？是的。
It's a bit. People are probably familiar with what American offices looked like in the 1950s from television or from movies, for example, the Billy Wilder film The Apartment, which came out in 1960. In the apartment, a personal favorite, Jack Lemmon plays a worker drone at an insurance company in Manhattan, who spends all day grasping at the ultimate status symbol, an office with a door. Having your own office was a huge relief, because in the main typing pool, your job wasn't much fun.
这是一个笑话。人们可能从电视或电影中熟悉 20 世纪 50 年代美式办公室的样子，例如比利·怀尔德 1960 年上映的电影《公寓春光》。在《公寓春光》这部个人最爱的电影中，杰克·莱蒙饰演曼哈顿一家保险公司的无名小卒，他整天都在拼命追求终极身份象征——一间带门的办公室。拥有自己的办公室是一种巨大的解脱，因为在主要的打字池里，你的工作并没有多少乐趣。
The space was cramped and noisy, but there was also a culture problem in white collar work. The office was supposed to be this kinder, gentler workplace than being on a factory floor. But factory thinking had infected white collar work, largely through a management strategy called Taylorism. It comes from the management theorist, Frederick Winsor Taylor, the father of scientific management of efficiency experts finding the one best way to do a task and to do it at the least amount of time possible. Even if you worked for a banker or an insurance company, it could feel like
空间狭窄而嘈杂，但白领工作也存在文化问题。办公室本应比工厂车间更温和、更友善。但工厂思维已经侵蚀了白领工作，主要通过一种名为泰勒制的管理策略。它来自管理理论家弗雷德里克·温斯罗普·泰勒，他是科学管理之父，也是效率专家，旨在寻找完成一项任务的唯一最佳方法，并以尽可能少的时间完成它。即使你在银行或保险公司工作，也可能会让你觉得
you were a faceless part of an assembly line. The office of the 1950s was ripe for a shakeup, and that's where Robert Propsd comes in. So Robert Propsd was a kind of freelance designer from Colorado, I mean, almost a kind of freelance intellectual. He didn't really have any particular interest. He just wanted to make improvements to systems. Props to write to local businesses like concrete suppliers or people who make playground equipment and he would say, Hey, I have no experience in your field, but I have a couple of ideas and you should pay me. He actually got quite a bit of work this way because Rhyber Props was really convincing.
你流水线上一个没有面孔的零件。20世纪50年代的办公室已经成熟，亟需一场大洗牌，这就是罗伯特·普罗普斯登场的时候。所以罗伯特·普罗普斯是来自科罗拉多州的一种自由职业设计人员，我的意思是，几乎是一种自由职业知识分子。他 realmente 没有任何特定的兴趣。他只是想对系统进行改进。普罗普斯写信给当地企业，比如混凝土供应商或游乐场设备制造商，他会说：“嘿，我在你的领域没有经验，但我有几个想法，你应该付钱给我。”事实上，他通过这种方式得到了相当多的工作，因为雷伯·普罗普斯真的很有说服力。
If you watch old speeches from Props, he comes across as a kind of abstract genius. Even if I have to be honest, I don't really know what he's talking about. I'm sure everybody is belabored by this idea that we're suffering or we're impacted by serious rate of change, but it's really the change in the rate of change now that is causing really fundamental changes for us.
如果你看普罗普斯的旧演讲，他给人的感觉就像是一种抽象的天才。即使我必须诚实地说，我真的不知道他在说什么。我确信每个人都为这个想法所困扰，即我们正在遭受痛苦，或者我们受到严重变化率的影响，但现在真正给我们带来根本性变化的是变化率的变化。
In 1958, Prok's went to the Aspen Design Conference, where he met the president of the furniture company, Herman Miller. Herman Miller was famous for its iconic Eames chairs and Nguu Chi tables, but the fancy furniture business wasn't a huge growth industry. Herman Miller wanted to expand its offerings. They brought probes out to Michigan and gave them a pretty broad mandate. Basically, just come up with new stuff Herman Miller could produce. Every day probes to its sit in his office and think, OK, what kind of products can we redesign?
1958年，普罗普斯去了阿斯彭设计会议，在那里他遇到了家具公司赫尔曼·米尔格的总裁。赫尔曼·米尔格以其标志性的伊姆斯椅和恩古·奇桌子而闻名，但高档家具业务并不是一个巨大的增长行业。赫尔曼·米尔格希望扩大其产品范围。他们把普罗普斯带到密歇根州，并给了他一个相当广泛的任务授权。基本上，就是想出赫尔曼·米尔格可以生产的新东西。每天普罗普斯都坐在他的办公室里想，好吧，我们可以重新设计什么样的产品？
And we're talking about things way beyond the scope of what the company was already making. Here's Amy Osherman, chief archivist at Herman Miller. Looking at problems such as cattle branding, or timber harvesting, or my personal favorite, they were working a bit with Kimberly Clark on a better sanitary napkin. Prope was pitching all these blue sky ideas, but eventually he settled on something that seemed pretty obvious for a furniture company. Office furniture.
我们谈论的事情远远超出了公司已经生产的范围。这是赫尔曼·米尔格的首席档案管理员艾米·奥舍曼。着眼于诸如牛只烙印、木材采伐等问题，或者我个人最喜欢的，他们与金佰利克拉克合作开发更好的卫生巾。普罗普斯提出了所有这些蓝天般的想法，但最终他锁定了一个对家具公司来说似乎相当明显的目标。办公家具。
Prope's noticed that the furniture that Herman Miller provided him with to outfit his own office weren't up to his standards. He thought it sucked. Around this time, the idea of the knowledge worker was becoming popular. This whole concept that many office workers weren't just drones. Accountants and copywriters and engineers, they needed a new kind of workplace for creative thinking. Props had been reading about a new trend in German design called Bureau Lawn Shoft, or the Office Landscape,
普罗普斯注意到赫尔曼·米尔格为他提供来布置他自己的办公室的家具不符合他的标准。他认为这糟透了。大约在这个时候，知识工作者的概念开始流行起来。整个概念是，许多办公室职员不仅仅是无名小卒。会计师、文案和工程师，他们需要一种用于创造性思考的新型工作场所。普罗普斯一直在阅读关于德国设计中一种名为 Bureau Lawn Shoft 或办公景观的新趋势，
which said office layouts had to be thought about in this more flexible way, and that people shouldn't be sitting in the same place all the time. It called for some radical new office setups. Here's Jennifer Kaufman-Bueller. She's a professor of design history at Purdue University. It was often described as chaotic, visually chaotic,
该趋势称必须以这种更灵活的方式考虑办公室布局，并且人们不应该总是坐在同一个地方。它呼吁进行一些激进的新办公室设置。这是詹妮弗·考夫曼-布勒。她是普渡大学设计史教授。它经常被描述为混乱的，视觉上混乱的，
because it was an open interior with no walls, really important to their concept. Probe's had been feeling too static in his Herman Miller office, but now he was inspired to change it. He teamed up with a mid-century furniture designer named George Nelson, and together, they devised a plan for the office
因为这是一个没有墙壁的开放式内部空间，对他们的概念非常重要。普罗普斯在他在赫尔曼·米尔格的办公室里一直感到过于静态，但现在他受到启发去改变它。他与一位名叫乔治·尼尔森的中世纪家具设计师合作，两人共同制定了办公室计划
of the future, one built around communication and movement. They called it the action office. The action office was a suite of furniture that included a couple of stations for each worker. There was a coffee table and a semi- and closed phone booth and a bookshelf and a standing desk, which I know that's common now, but it was pretty unique at the time. All of it was made with high quality materials, like cast aluminum and rosewood. The action office was designed around a couple of principles. One was the idea that workers get more done when they have to move around.
未来，一个围绕交流和运动建立的办公室。他们称之为行动办公室。行动办公室是一套家具，包括为每个工人提供的一些工作站。有一个咖啡桌、一个半封闭的电话亭、一个书架和一个站立式办公桌，我知道这现在很常见，但在当时是相当独特的。所有这些都是用高质量材料制成的，如压铸铝和红木。行动办公室是围绕几个原则设计的。一个是员工在必须四处走动时工作效率更高的想法。
That was what was the spirit behind action office. Maybe one at some point you're standing working at your desk, maybe you need to move to a different setting to take a phone call, you're not sitting at one particular place doing the same thing over and over again. The second principle behind action office was that a small amount of clutter was actually a good thing. The action office didn't include a filing cabinet, but instead there was a roll top desk that could hold all of your important papers, but not Hide all of your important papers. Propes believe that if you file something away, you might as well throw it out, and that filing cabinets create
这就是行动办公室背后的精神。也许在某个时候，你站着在办公桌前工作，也许你需要搬到一个不同的环境来接听电话，而不是坐在一个特定的地方一遍又一遍地做同一件事。行动办公室背后的第二个原则是，少量的杂乱其实是一件好事。行动办公室不包括文件柜，取而代之的是一个可以容纳你所有重要文件但又不会隐藏你所有重要文件的卷顶桌。普罗普斯认为，如果你把某东西归档收好，你还不如把它扔掉，而且文件柜会产生
Unmanageable backlogs of information. This idea was rooted in Propes' very particular philosophy about the brain's capacity to retain information. very particular philosophy about the brain's capacity to retain information. The mind can grapple with seven things plus or minus two, so people can handle line things at a time, some people only handle five. But if you try to manage information in more units in that, then you can quickly bargain. This is a kind of phenomenon we see all the time with too many papers on your desk, or too many things on your desk or too many things happening at the same time.
无法管理的信息积压。这个想法植根于普罗普斯关于大脑保留信息能力的非常特殊的哲学中。非常独特的哲学，关于大脑保留信息的能力。大脑可以处理七个正负两项的事物，所以人们一次可以处理九项事物，有些人只能处理五项。但是，如果你试图在比这更多的单元中管理信息，那么你很快就会破产。这种现象我们在桌子上有太多纸张，或者桌子上有太多东西，或者同时发生太多事情时经常看到。
The third principle of the action office was workers should have a little bit of privacy, but not too much. The design is open, and workers are always right in the middle of the action. Each employee has their station, with their desk and their coffee table and their phone booth, but the stations aren't supposed to be walled off. In 1964, Robert Probst and George Nelson unveiled the action office to the public. They sold it as a new utopian vision of the workplace, complete with gorgeous, high-in furniture, and a layout that would make workers happier and more efficient.
行动办公室的第三个原则是员工应该有一点隐私，但又不能太多。设计是开放的，员工始终处于行动的中心。每个员工都有他们的工作站，有他们的办公桌、咖啡桌和电话亭，但工作站不应该被墙壁隔开。1964年，罗伯特·普罗普斯和乔治·尼尔森向公众推出了行动办公室。他们将其作为工作场所的新乌托邦愿景进行销售，辅以华丽的高端家具和使员工更快乐、更高效的布局。
The action office wasn't just a set of furniture. It was a way of life. And yet, the action office was a bust. Businesses just didn't get it. Like, why should we spend all this money on fancy coffee tables and phone booths for secretaries and filing clerks? Even if your company wanted to buy the action office, the price tag was just too high. Even if your company wanted to buy the action office, the price tag was just too high. It requires a lot of space, and it's also fairly expensive. There were high quality materials, and this is really the influence of George Nelson. And as a result, it was widely admired, but not widely adopted. The action office was a commercial flop, but Robert Prope wasn't ready to give up on the idea. He went back to the drawing board and we thought his entire
行动办公室不仅仅是一套家具。它是一种生活方式。然而，行动办公室却是一个彻底的失败。企业根本不理解。比如，为什么我们要花这么多钱为秘书和文书人员购买花哨的咖啡桌和电话亭？即使你的公司想买行动办公室，价格标签也太高了。即使你的公司想买行动办公室，价格标签也太高了。它需要大量的空间，而且也相当昂贵。有高质量的材料，这真的是乔治·尼尔森的影响。因此，它广受赞誉，但并未被广泛采用。行动办公室是一个商业上的失败，但罗伯特·普罗普斯并没有准备放弃这个想法。他回到了绘图板前，重新思考了他的整个
approach and then he returned three years later with action office too. You and I are today living in industries finest hour, an age of hurry and in this super fast smart effective age, there are millions of people who still work in old-fashioned offices, and haven't stopped to realize they still work in old-fashioned offices. Now we'd like you to think about Herman Miller's action office. Like many sequels, action office 2 was less interesting than the first one. Instead of aluminum and solid hardwood, the new designs featured lots of
方法，然后在三年后带着行动办公室 2 回归。你和我今天生活在行业中最美好的时代，一个匆忙的时代，在这个超级快节奏、聪明、高效的时代，有数百万人仍然在老式办公室里工作，并且还没有停下来意识到他们仍然在老式办公室里工作。现在我们希望你考虑一下赫尔曼·米尔格的行动办公室。就像许多续集一样，行动办公室 2 没有第一部那么有趣。新设计没有采用铝和实木，而是采用了大量的
plastics and laminates, which brought the price way down, but the mid-century modernist furniture aesthetic, that was gone. And along with it, the designer George Nelson. Here's Amy Osherman. Nelson got booted from the project because there was too much spice between him and probes. They just straight up didn't like each other. Without Nelson in the mix, the new furniture kit looked a lot more conventional. There wasn't a phone booth or a coffee table. The standing desk became a normal high desk, and the stool became a regular office chair. Charles Eames went on to deem action office to honest ugly.
塑料和层压板，这大大降低了价格，但中世纪现代主义家具美学消失了。随之而去的还有设计师乔治·尼尔森。这是艾米·奥舍曼。尼尔森被踢出了这个项目，因为他和普罗普斯之间有太多的摩擦。他们简直就是合不来。没有尼尔森的参与，这套新家具看起来要传统得多。没有电话亭，也没有咖啡桌。站立式办公桌变成了一个普通的高办公桌，凳子变成了普通的办公椅。查尔斯·埃姆斯后来认为行动办公室 2 是诚实的丑陋。
So there was very much a big style and aesthetic difference between the heavy hitters of those times. There was one more big change. The action office to included lightweight, easy to install, fabric covered panels. They were really functional. The fabric muffled sound,
因此，那个时代的大腕之间存在着非常大的风格和美学差异。还有一个大的变化。行动办公室 2 包括轻量、易于安装、织物覆盖的面板。它们非常实用。织物减弱了声音，
and you could move them around to create this sense of privacy. If, at some point in the middle of your workday, you needed to have an impromptu conference or workroom, you could then spread out or angle the three balls differently. Props included very particular instructions on how to use them. In his mind, three panels should be hooked up to make a kind of half hexagon shape.
你可以四处移动它们来营造这种隐私感。如果在你工作日的中间的某个时候，你需要召开即兴会议或工作坊，你可以展开或以不同角度放置这三个面板。普罗普斯包含了关于如何使用它们的非常具体的说明。在他的脑海中，应该连接三个面板来制造一种半六边形形状。
It looked like a small amphitheater. But probes also included a prophetic warning about the panels. Don't absolutely do not take these panels and make them into a right-angled box that encloses the employee. If you do that, the whole idea of open communication and teamwork goes right out the window. Props was very clear about all this. He was out-to-gate prescribing the best ways
它看起来像一个小型露天剧场。但普罗普斯还包括关于面板的预言性警告。绝对不要，绝对不要拿这些面板把它们变成一个包围员工的直角盒子。如果你这样做，开放式沟通和团队合作的整个想法就会烟消云散。普罗普斯对此非常清楚。他在一出门就开出了最佳方法的处方
to configure these panel systems that very clearly stated, do not enclose people. No boxes, no enclosures, just open lines of communication. This stuff is important. Well, despite all those warnings, I think you know where this is going. The action office too became the prototype for the cubicle. The new action office sold like a blockbuster.
来配置这些面板系统，这些系统非常清楚地说明，不要把人包围起来。没有盒子，没有围栏，只有开放的沟通渠道。这些东西很重要。好吧，尽管有所有的警告，我想你知道这是怎么回事。行动办公室 2 成为了隔间的原型。新的行动办公室像大片一样畅销。
Herman Miller sales went up by $10 million after it was introduced, and it spawned a series of knockoffs. And while most of these knockoffs had fabric walls, they weren't mobile, as probes had intended. The companies buying the action office and its imitators were not respecting the wishes of Robert Probst. They started installing the fabric panels at right angles and making boxes, and the workers started feeling him then.
在其推出后，赫尔曼·米尔格的销售额增加了 1000 万美元，并催生了一系列山寨货。虽然大多数这些山寨货都有织物墙，但它们不像普罗普斯预期的那样是移动的。购买行动办公室及其模仿者的公司没有尊重罗伯特·普罗普斯的愿望。他们开始以直角安装织物面板并制作盒子，工人们开始感到被困住了。
It became clear that these three walls could very quickly become a box, and you could cram as many workers as possible, as quickly as possible, as cheaply as possible into as little space as possible. George Nelson was the designer booted off the Action Office project, and he was not happy with the Action Office 2 and all of its imitators. He wrote a critical memo in 1970 saying, one does not have to be an especially perceptive critic to realize that Action Office 2 is definitely not a system which produces an environment gratifying for people
很明显，这三面墙很快就会变成一个盒子，你可以在尽可能小的空间里尽可能快、尽可能便宜地塞进尽可能多的工人。乔治·尼尔森是被踢出行动办公室项目的设计人员，他对行动办公室 2 及其所有模仿者并不满意。他在 1970 年写了一份批评备忘录，称人们不必是一个特别敏锐的评论家，就能意识到行动办公室 2 绝对不是一个为人们营造令人满意环境的系统
in general. But it is admirable for planners looking for ways of cramming in a maximum number of bodies. George Nelson was bitter, but he had a point. The action office was supposed to solve the problems of the open 50-style office, but now instead of loud offices with no privacy, people were becoming enclosed and trapped inside these giant fabric walls,
总的来说。但对于寻找塞入最大数量身体的方法的规划人员来说，它是令人钦佩的。乔治·尼尔森很痛苦，但他说的有道理。行动办公室本应解决 50 年代风格的开放式办公室的问题，但现在，人们没有在没有隐私的嘈杂办公室里，而是被包围并困在这些巨大的织物墙内，
which got smaller and smaller over time. Here's Jennifer Kaufman-Bueller. By the 90s, you get this sort of image of the cubicle as a tool of isolation. There is this really interesting contradiction that happens that this is all created to facilitate communication. And then the very thing that is meant to improve communication becomes a symbol of isolation. The depressing cubicle was a mirror for other trends in the white color workplace.
随着时间的推移，它们变得越来越小。这是詹妮弗·考夫曼-布勒。到了 90 年代，你得到了这种隔间作为孤立工具的形象。发生了一个非常有趣的矛盾，即这一切都是为了促进沟通而创建的。然后，旨在改善沟通的东西成为了孤立的象征。令人沮丧的隔间是白领工作场所其他趋势的镜子。
The US went through a recession in the late 80s and American businesses started quote trimming the fat and quote downsizing, which, of course, really just means they fired a lot of people. Between 1990 and 1992, 1.1 million American workers were laid off, and workers that remained had very few protections. Only 11% of American workers in the private sector were unionized by the early 1990s. If the apartment is the defining office pop culture of the 50s, the cubicle era is captured by more depressing works of art, like Dilbert, or the movie Office Space.
美国在 80 年代末经历了一次经济衰退，美国企业开始引用“精简脂肪”和引用“精简规模”，这当然真的只是意味着他们解雇了很多人。在 1990 年到 1992 年之间，110 万美国工人被解雇，留下来的工人几乎没有保护。到 90 年代初，只有 11% 的美国私营部门工人加入了工会。如果公寓是 50 年代定义的办公室流行文化，那么隔间时代就被更令人沮丧的艺术作品所捕捉，比如《呆伯特》或电影《办公空间》。
So I was sitting in my cubicle today and I realized, ever since I started working, every single day in my life has been worse than the day before it. So that means that every single day that you see me, that's on the worst day of my life. It's just this fundamental protest against not just the setting of office work, but the kind of work that's being done in the way that people are being treated. So, design in this sense, the cubicle, the hatred of the cubicle is really tied up with an overall sense that American work and workplaces
所以我今天坐在我的隔间里，我意识到，自从我开始工作以来，我生命中的每一天都比前一天更糟。所以这意味着你看到的我的每一天，都是我生命中最糟糕的一天。这只是一种对办公室工作环境的根本抗议，不仅是对办公室工作环境的抗议，也是对正在进行的这种工作以及对待人们的方式的抗议。因此，从这个意义上说，设计，隔间，对隔间的仇恨，实际上与美国工作和工作场所是一种冷酷无情且失败的场所的整体感觉紧密相连。
are really callous and unfailing places. I, uh, I don't like my job, and, uh, I don't think I'm gonna go anymore. You're just not gonna go? Yeah. Won't you get fired? I don't know. Robert Prope's lived long enough to see the rise of the cubicle.
我，呃，我不喜欢我的工作，而且，呃，我想我再也不去了。你只是不去了？对。你不会被解雇吗？我不知道。罗伯特·普罗普斯活得够长，看到了隔间的崛起。
In 1997, he gave an interview to the New York Times, where he called the new wave of cubicles monolithic insanity, but he didn't think his designs were the problem. I mean, I think he's super proud of everything that he accomplished as he should be. He's had like a really interesting career. But he said something, he said that the dark side of most organizations is that they're not intelligent or progressive. And he said, lots are run by craft people who can take the same kind of equipment and create hellholes.
1997年，他接受了《纽约时报》的采访，在采访中他称新一波的隔间为“整体疯狂”，但他不认为他的设计有问题。我的意思是，我认为他为自己所取得的一切成就感到超级自豪，他也应该如此。他有着一段非常有趣的事业。但他说了一句话，他说大多数组织的黑暗面是它们既不聪明也不进步。并且他说，很多组织是由那些可以拿走同一种设备并创造出人间地狱的工匠经营的。
Probe's defended the action office and his original designs. He offered these words of wisdom. One of the dumbest things you can do is sit in one space and let the world pass you by. By the early 2000s, the cubicle was on the way out, and it was replaced by a kind of modern open plan, which was popular with Silicon Valley. Like in the 50s, you saw workers sitting at long rows of connected desks, but there was a twist. Here's Allison Areff, who writes about workplace design.
普罗普斯为行动办公室和他的原始设计进行了辩护。他提供了这些智慧的话语。你能做的最蠢的事情之一就是坐在一个空间里，让世界与你擦肩而过。到 21 世纪初，隔间正在走向消亡，取而代之的是一种硅谷流行的一种现代开放式平面图。就像在 50 年代一样，你看到工人们坐成一排长长的相连的办公桌，但有一个转折。这是艾莉森·阿雷夫，她撰写关于工作场所设计的文章。
In the era of the .com boom once, I would say that the absence of office furniture became the thing, right? I'm one of you. I don't need a corner office. Marcus Ackerberg famously sits in the middle of all of his employees. He's just one of the guys, right? So having fancy furniture is not in your interest. The modern open plan had another big difference from the style of the 1950s. In the new layout, there aren't any noisy typewriters or loud telephone calls. You know, what's different about American offices now is that they're overwhelmingly quiet. You actually walk into an open office plan and they're deathly quiet. People with their headphones in, headphones have become the new walls. Much like the cubicle, the modern open plan was promoted with utopian language.
在网络泡沫时代，我想说的是，办公家具的缺失成为了关键，对吧？我和你一样。我不需要转角办公室。马克·扎克伯格出名地坐在所有员工中间。他只是其中一员，对吧？所以拥有花哨的家具对你没有好处。现代开放式平面图与 20世纪50年代的风格有另一个重大区别。在新布局中，没有任何嘈杂的打字机或响亮的电话呼叫。你知道，现在美式办公室的不同之处在于它们异常安静。你实际上走进一个开放式办公室计划，它们死一般寂静。戴着耳机的员工，耳机已经成为新的墙壁。就像隔间一样，现代开放式平面图是用乌托邦式的语言宣传的。
They said, oh my god, this is so amazing. We have all this collaborative collisions and spontaneous interactions because everyone's in here. Look, your boss is right there. Think of all the communicating you're going to do. Now that you're free of the tyranny of the cubicle, well, the opposite has happened. Harvard Business School says in-person communication has actually dropped 70% of companies that shifted to this kind of open-plan office. That's because, frankly, it's kind of awkward to talk to somebody when they have their headphones in, and now we have tools like email and Slack.
他们说，哦，天哪，这太棒了。我们拥有所有这些协作碰撞和自发互动，因为每个人都在这里。看，你的老板就在那里。想想你要进行的所有沟通。既然你摆脱了隔间的暴政，好吧，相反的情况发生了。哈佛商学院表示，转向这种开放式办公室的公司的人际沟通实际上下降了 70%。这是因为，坦率地说，当某人戴着耳机时与他们交谈有点尴尬，现在我们有了电子邮件和 Slack 等工具。
And besides, if you do wanna talk to somebody, everybody in the office can hear you. Because at these companies, workers have very little personal space. So, you know, Facebook, when they were first emerging as a company, they bought the old-sund micrassystems building in Menlo Park and doubled the amount of people in the same office space.
此外，如果你想和某人交谈，办公室里的每个人都能听到你。因为在这些公司里，员工的个人空间非常少。所以，你知道，Facebook，当他们刚作为一家公司兴起时，他们买下了门洛帕克的旧太阳微系统公司大楼，并将同一办公空间里的人数增加了一倍。
So they took square footage and doubled the amount of people in the same office space. So they took square footage and doubled the amount of people in that square foot. 12 years ago, offices had an average of 225 square feet per employee. By 2017, that number had dropped to 151 square feet, and it's even lower today. Two years ago, there was a pandemic. Maybe you heard about it, and millions of people made a very abrupt transition to work
所以他们拿了平方英尺，把同一办公空间里的人数增加了一倍。所以他们拿了平方英尺，把那个平方英尺里的人数增加了一倍。12年前，办公室平均每个员工有 225 平方英尺。到 2017 年，这个数字下降到 151 平方英尺，而今天甚至更低。两年前，发生了一场大流行。也许你听说过，数百万人非常突然地过渡到居家办公
from home. This raised so many questions about how much we really need a physical office. Like maybe the next era is just a permanent shift to remote work, like the total death of office space. But the experts I spoke to, they don't think that's likely. Instead, many office workers have already gone back, even just for one or two days a week. So assuming that there's still a physical office,
从家里。这引发了关于我们究竟有多需要实体办公室的许多问题。就像也许下一个时代只是向远程办公的永久转变，就像办公空间的彻底死亡。但我交谈过的专家认为这不太可能。相反，许多办公室职员已经回去了，哪怕只是每周一两天。所以假设仍然有一个实体办公室，
what is it going to look like? Last October, I attended Neocon, the world's largest office furniture expo. Okay, so I didn't actually go to Chicago, where they hold it every year, but I did attend virtually. And scrolling through all the exhibits, I noticed a couple of trends. One was design meant to address health and safety, you know, better ventilation, more space in the office for social distancing, stuff like that. I also saw lots of design ideas about improving the aesthetics of the office, things like res-emercial furniture,
它会是什么样子？去年 10 月，我参加了 Neocon，全球最大的办公家具博览会。好吧，我其实并没有去每年举办它的芝加哥，但我确实虚拟参加了。翻看所有的展品，我注意到了一些趋势。一个是旨在解决健康和安全问题的设计，你知道，更好的通风，办公室里更多的社交距离空间，诸如此类的事情。我还看到了很多关于改善办公室美学的设计理念，比如住宅式商业家具，
the soft couches and the nice wallpaper that make your office feel like a living room. I also noticed a couple of designers who were borrowing pretty liberally from the action office. These products are mobile, and they allow the users to move and create the ideal setup for their needs at hand, whether it be creating a private setting
柔软的沙发和精美的壁纸，让你的办公室感觉像一个起居室。我还注意到一些设计师非常自由地借鉴了行动办公室。这些产品是移动的，它们允许用户移动并为他们手头的需求创建理想的设置，无论是创建私密的设置
or one that fosters collaboration. I even saw presentations about privacy pods, which to my eyes looked an awful lot like cubicles. The cubicle may be poised for a comeback, but in a techie, nightmare-going way. Last year Google announced plans to pilot a new kind of inflatable cubicle in their offices, a plastic wall that fills with air to create a makeshift privacy barrier if a worker needs to take a phone call. I know, it feels like an episode of Silicon Valley, right? That someone's just standing there waiting for the thing to blow off and it's just like taking a really long time.
还是促进合作的设置。我甚至看到了关于隐私舱的演示，在我看来，这看起来非常像隔间。隔间可能准备卷土重来，但以一种科技、噩梦般的方式。去年，谷歌宣布计划在他们的办公室里试点一种新型的充气隔间，这是一种充满空气的塑料墙，如果员工需要接听电话，就可以创建一个权宜之计的隐私屏障。我知道，这感觉就像是《硅谷》的一集，对吧？有人就站在那里等着这东西吹起来，而这就像是花了很长时间。
There's a couple of major problems with all of these design solutions for the office. One is how they ignore a lot of people. Most designers are focused exclusively on products for white collar workers, and there just isn't as much interest in factory workers, or coffee shop baristas, or public school teachers, or all the other people we started calling essential workers two years ago. I've really looked very hard to find any amount of attention paid to workplaces that are not white-collar workers' work spaces. And there just isn't any attention paid to them. I don't think anyone's thinking long and hard about, is this cashier's space comfortable? Is this bus driver's seat the safest it could be,
所有这些办公室设计解决方案都存在几个主要问题。一个是它们如何忽视了很多人。大多数设计师都专注于白领员工的产品，对于工厂工人、咖啡店咖啡师、公立学校教师或我们在两年前开始称之为基本工人的所有其他人，没有那么多的兴趣。我真的非常努力地寻找对非白领员工工作场所的任何程度的关注。根本没有对他们的关注。我认为没有人会苦思冥想，这个收银员的空间舒适吗？这个公交车司机的座位是它能做到的最安全的地方吗，
and is it a comfortable place to sit all day? The other issue with design solutions for the office is that a new chair isn't going to fix problems that need to be addressed with policy, problems like a lack of access to childcare, or stagnant wages that don't keep up with inflation, or the inflexibility of the eight-hour work day, which makes it impossible for lots of people to take care of their older parents or kids. But if you're a beleaguered corporate manager, it's hard to redesign the work week or provide childcare.
而且整天坐在那里是一个舒适的地方吗？办公室设计解决方案的另一个问题是，一把新椅子无法解决需要通过政策解决的问题，诸如缺乏获得托儿服务的途径、跟不上通货膨胀停滞的工资，或者八小时工作制的缺乏灵活性，这使得许多人无法照顾他们年迈的父母或孩子。但如果你是一个饱受困扰的企业经理，重新设计工作周或提供托儿服务是很困难的。
It's much easier to just bring in some new furniture and call it a day. There is this fantasy that we can, you know, change the physical environment of the office and that will dramatically and radically change what's done in the office. And there is this real belief in the kind of power of design to transform the everyday functioning of the office. And I think just as the office could never have fixed all the problems, it also isn't really the sole cause of all those problems.
只需引入一些新家具并宣布收工要容易得多。有一种幻想，我们可以，你知道，改变办公室的物理环境，这将显著且根本地改变办公室里所做的事情。并且确实有一种对设计能够改变办公室日常运作的力量的真正信仰。我认为正如办公室永远不可能解决所有问题一样，它也不是所有这些问题的唯一根源。
Look, standing desks and ergonomic chairs, they're great. They can make your work life a lot better, but relying on nice furniture to fix the office, well, that's just rearranging air-on chairs on the Titanic. We need to look at more long-term fixes. If the apartment represents the office of the 50s and office space is the 90s, then
看，站立式办公桌和人体工学椅子，它们很棒。它们可以让你的工作生活好很多，但依靠漂亮的家具来修复办公室，好吧，那只是在泰坦尼克号上重新排列铁椅子。我们需要寻找更多长期的修复方法。如果公寓代表了 50 年代办公室，而办公空间是 90 年代的办公室，那么
maybe the Utopian office is represented by a little movie from the 80s called 9 to 5. 9 to 5 is such a good example. I always say it really is in many ways a movie about office design because of course at the start of the film you have this dreary bullpen, very monochromatic and everyone he's miserable. Okay, so a spoiler alert for a movie that came up 42 years ago, but at the end of 9-5, Dolly Parton, Jane Fonda and Lily Tomlin have kidnapped their horrible misogynist boss, and with him gone, they make some changes around the office, really good changes,
也许乌托邦式的办公室是由 80 年代一部名为《九到五》的小电影代表的。《九到五》就是一个很好的例子。我总是说它在许多方面确实是一部关于办公室设计的电影，因为当然在电影开始时你拥有这个沉闷的 bullpen，非常单调，每个人都很痛苦。好吧，所以这是一个针对 42 年前上映的电影的剧透警告，但在《九到五》结束时，多莉·帕顿、简·方达和莉莉·汤姆林绑架了他们可怕的厌女症老板，随着他的离开，他们在办公室周围做了一些改变，非常好的改变，
like they started Daycare Center, and a job-sharing program, so employees can work flexible hours. And then we find out about all of those changes in policy that have really transformed the culture of the workplace. Our Daycare Center has been open now for two weeks. It's been wonderfully successful. Really? Yes. Our working parents love it. In the movie, they changed around the furniture in the office,
比如他们开办了一个日托中心和一个工作分享计划，以便员工可以灵活工作时间。然后我们了解了所有那些真正改变了工作场所文化的政策变化。我们的日托中心现在已经开业两周了。它取得了巨大的成功。真的吗？是的。我们的双职工父母很喜欢它。在电影中，他们改变了办公室里的家具，
but the furniture didn't fix everything. The real fix is something we should have tried a long time ago. They put Dolly Parton in charge. You are not off the clock yet. We have more big thoughts on the future of work after this. Support for this four-part series exploring the future of health and well-being comes from the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation, which is committed to improving health and health equity in the United States. Knowing that the healthy, equitable future that we all deserve won't simply arrive, RWJF
但家具并没有解决一切。真正的解决办法是我们早就应该尝试的。他们让多莉·帕顿负责。你还没有下班。在这之后，我们对工作的未来有更多的宏大想法。支持这个探讨健康和福祉未来的四部分系列的资金来自罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会，该基金会致力于改善美国的健康状况和健康公平。深知我们所有人应得的健康、公平的未来不会轻易到来，RWJF
is exploring how new technologies, scientific discoveries, cultural shifts, and unversing events like COVID, as we talk about in today's story, may shape our lives in years to come. Through these explorations, they're learning what it will take to build a future that provides every individual with a fair and just opportunity to thrive, no matter who they are, where they live, or how much money they have.
正在探索新技术、科学发现、文化转变以及像新冠疫情这样突如其来的事件（正如我们在今天的故事中所谈到的那样）将如何在未来几年塑造我们的生活。通过这些探索，他们正在了解构建一个为每个人提供公平和公正的繁荣机会的未来需要什么，无论他们是谁，他们住在哪里，或者他们有多少钱。
Learn more about their efforts at rwjf.org. So Chris, you've been working on this story about the future of offices since the summer, and a lot of things kind of have changed back and forth about what we think the future of the office might be. Oh, you think so, really? I haven't noticed in those cases. Yeah, there are two things that are really difficult about this story. One is the back and forth, as we're talking right now, we're at this point where lots of companies, despite Omicron,
访问 rwjf.org 了解更多关于他们的努力。所以克里斯，你从夏天开始就一直在创作这个关于办公室未来的故事，关于我们对办公室未来可能是什么样子的看法，很多事情一直在来回变化。哦，你这么认为，真的吗？我在这些情况下没有注意到。是的，这个故事有两个非常困难的地方。一个是来回变化，正如我们现在所谈论的，我们处于这样一个时刻：尽管有奥密克戎，
I guess maybe with the idea Omicron is starting to wane a little bit or calling people back in. So we've heard, you know, Citibank, for example, a lot of financial companies are doing that. Some companies like Apple are saying, we want everybody to come back into the office, but we don't know when. We're just going to wait until things are a bit better, but we do want you to come back. And then lots of companies are saying, like, don't worry about it. You could work from home, including 99% visible, I should say, unless you want me to like get out of playing the Oakland tomorrow that I don't know about. Maybe that's something you'll tell me later.
我想也许带着奥密克戎开始消退一点的想法或正在召回人们。所以我们听到，你知道，花旗银行，例如，许多金融公司都在这样做。一些公司，如苹果，说，我们希望每个人都回到办公室，但我们不知道什么时候。我们只是要等到情况好一点，但我们确实希望你回来。然后很多公司说，比如，不用担心。你可以在家工作，包括 99% Visible，我应该说，除非你想让我明天离开我在奥克兰的演出，而我对此一无所知。也许那是你以后会告诉我的事情。
That is not the plan. Yeah. But the other thing, aside from the way that everything is changing, is that people's individual situations are so different, right? Like, I spoke to a dozen 99PI listeners last fall about their experience with the office and I had 12 very different stories. Like some people love the commute because it gives them time to think and reflect. Some people, you know, hate the commute,
这不是计划。是的。但另一件事，除了万物都在变化的方式之外，是每个人的个人情况都非常不同，对吧？比如，去年秋天我采访了十几位 99PI 听众关于他们在办公室的经历，我有 12 个非常不同的故事。就像有些人喜欢通勤，因为它给他们时间思考和反思。有些人，你知道，讨厌通勤，
never wanted again. Some people want the camaraderie of the office. Other people realize they work much better at home. So that has been a really hard thing with the story is figuring out kind of all that balance. Yeah, yeah, I bet. So the story was mainly about the office and maybe the folly of thinking that furniture will change a whole lot when it comes to the office. But as we've been at home more, I think about my office situation at home. And this is a huge part of the future of the office is our conditions at home, by know, by ourselves, or conditions made by our Lonesome. Yeah, I didn't talk too much about remote work in the piece. So I did an interview with Anne Helen Peterson, who is a journalist who writes a newsletter called Culture
再也不想要了。有些人想要办公室的 camaraderie（同事情谊）。其他人意识到他们在家里工作得更好。所以这对于这个故事来说一直是一件非常困难的事情，弄清楚所有这些平衡。是的，是的，我敢打赌。所以这个故事主要是关于办公室的，也许认为家具会在办公室方面改变很多的想法是愚蠢的。但随着我们在家里呆的时间更多，我想到了我在家里的办公室情况。这是办公室未来的很大一部分，是我们家里的条件，我知道，靠我们自己，或者是我们独自一人的条件。是的，我在文章中没有太多谈论远程工作。所以我采访了安·海伦·彼得森，她是一位撰写名为 Culture 的简报的记者
Study, and she recently co-authored a book with her partner, Charlie Worsell, called Out of Office, which is about the future of remote work. So I just wanted to add that as our Coda to the story today, just to talk about remote work, which is not going to become the dominant form of work. I think we were saying the office is never going away. Yeah, well, the office isn't going away and probably remote work isn't going away.
研究，她最近和她的伴侣查理·沃瑟尔（Charlie Worsell）合著了一本名为《办公室之外》（Out of Office）的书，探讨的是远程工作的未来。所以我今天只是想把这一点作为我们故事的尾声，聊聊远程工作，它不会成为工作的主导形式。我想我们之前说过，办公室永远不会消失。是的，办公室不会消失，而且可能远程工作也不会消失。
Like we've found like a different sort of hybrid for what life is probably going to be like in the future. Okay, so here's my interview with Anne Helen Peterson, where we discuss the promise and some of the unintended consequences of remote work. Hi, Anne. So we've had this great kind of proof of concept for working from home during the pandemic, and now there's a rush to go back to the office. Does it feel like a missed opportunity to make remote work a normal part of our work life?
就像我们找到了未来生活可能呈现的某种不同类型的混合模式。好的，这就是我与安·海伦·彼得森（Anne Helen Peterson）的访谈，我们在访谈中探讨了远程工作的前景以及一些意料之外的后果。嗨，安。在疫情期间，我们针对居家办公做了一个非常棒的概念验证，现在大家都急着回到办公室。把远程工作变成我们工作生活中的常态，是不是感觉错过了一个好机会？
Yeah, and I will say that there are a lot of companies that are and have been for the last, you know, I don't know, year and a half, have been thinking about this in really interesting ways. So even a place like Microsoft, which before the pandemic was very much, like you must live in Seattle, you must come into the office, even though it's a horrendous commute every day to the suburbs. You know, like they had had previously been very, very stringent about allowing people
是的，而且我想说的是，有很多公司在过去的一年半时间里，一直都在以非常有趣的方式思考这个问题。比如微软这样的公司，在大流行之前，他们非常强调你必须住在西雅图，你必须来办公室上班，尽管每天去郊区的通勤是一场噩梦。你知道的，他们以前对允许员工
to work from home in most positions. And I think from everything that I've heard, they are completely reconsidering that position. And part of it too is that they realize that they have to compete with other tech companies that are offering more flexible works scenarios. But then there are other companies like Apple right now that is apparently like a very big stickler
在大多数职位上在家办公有着非常严格的规定。据我所知，他们正在彻底重新考虑这一立场。部分原因也是因为他们意识到，他们必须与提供更灵活工作方案的其他科技公司进行竞争。但与此同时，还有其他公司，比如苹果公司，目前显然非常坚持
in terms of like, we have this beautiful office and you will come into it. Yeah, I feel like the other side of that is I was reading about designers who believe the office has to be less homey now. Things like free snacks, it's keeping people in the office too long, and that maybe if we got rid of some of those amenities, it would be healthier for people because they're not staying at the office for 14, 16 hour work days. I just thought that was really interesting.
这样一种观点，即我们有这么漂亮的办公室，你们就得来上班。是的，我觉得硬币的另一面是，我看到有设计师认为现在的办公室必须少一些家的感觉。比如免费零食，这让人们在办公室待的时间太长了，也许如果我们取消其中一些便利设施，对人们的健康会更好，因为他们就不会在办公室工作14到16个小时了。我只是觉得这真的很有趣。
Yeah, and I think that that is a gesture or an attempt to think about things like equity, because if you have a group of people who are going to be working from home more in order to attend a caregiving responsibilities, I'm not talking about like watching your kid and also working. I'm talking about my kid gets done with school at three and someone needs to watch him for a half an hour until he goes into after school. Carry whatever those things are. A lot of those people are going to be parents and a lot of them are going to be moms. And so we don't want to have this split workforce that's, you know, the secondary workforce
是的，我认为这是一种姿态，或者说是为了考虑公平问题而做出的一种尝试。因为如果你有一群人，为了兼顾照顾家庭的责任而需要更多地在家办公——我不是指一边看孩子一边工作那种，我说的是我的孩子三点放学，需要有人照看半小时直到他去参加课后活动，诸如此类的事情。这其中很多人会是父母，而很多人会是妈妈。所以我们不希望出现这种分裂的劳动力队伍，也就是次要的劳动力队伍
is working from home. And then the primary workforce that is getting the FaceTime with managers and executives are the ones that are in the office who don't have caregiving and responsibilities, right? Like that's going to lead to a lot of inequities. And so they're trying to think about, how can we make the office less appealing? I've been working remotely through all this.
在家里工作，而主要的劳动力队伍则是那些留在办公室里、能和经理及高管面对面交流、且没有照顾家庭负担的人，对吧？这会导致很多不公平。所以他们正在努力思考，我们怎样才能让办公室变得不那么吸引人？我一直都在远程工作。
I understand you've been doing that too. There's a lot of things I find really healthy and satisfying about it. Like I don't miss commuting for two hours, which I used to do. But what are some of the unintended consequences of remote work for people who've had to make that switch? I think a lot of people have found just how slippery work is, right? It can ooze into all of the different crevices in our lives.
据我了解你也是这样。我发现其中有很多非常健康且令人满意的地方。比如我不用再忍受长达两小时的通勤了，我以前经常那样。但对于不得不做出这种转变的人来说，远程工作的一些意料之外的后果是什么？我认为很多人发现工作是多么难以捉摸，对吧？它会渗入我们生活的方方面面。
And some people kept that at bay, previously through the natural on and off ramps of commuting. So my work starts when I get into the office or at delineation, like they still were checking emails when they got home. I think at the beginning of the pandemic a lot of people were very anxious about their jobs and about demonstrating their commitment to their jobs and that turned into habits of rollover, start working while you're still in bed looking at your phone, work all day and then at the end of the day, you don't have a social life because you're not seeing other people. So you keep working. So I think that there are habits that were put in place during that time,
有些人以前通过通勤自然建立的开始和结束的缓冲地带，将工作隔绝在外。所以我的工作在我进入办公室时开始，或者有明确的界限，尽管他们回到家后依然会查阅邮件。我认为在大流行初期，很多人对自己的工作以及如何向公司证明自己的承诺感到非常焦虑，这就变成了连轴转的习惯：一边躺在床上看手机一边开始工作，工作一整天，然后到了晚上，由于见不到其他人，你连社交生活都没有了。所以你继续工作。因此我认为有些习惯就是在那个时期养成的，
but we haven't really figured out how to create any sort of boundaries around where work is in our lives or any sort of buffer space. So when people say to me, I miss the commute. Do they miss being packed on the F-Train for 45 minutes during rush hour? Do they miss being in stop and go traffic on a freeway? In the rain? No, they don't miss that at all.
但我们还没有真正弄清楚如何围绕生活中工作的位置建立任何形式的边界，或者任何类型的缓冲空间。所以当人们对我说，我想念通勤。他们是在怀念高峰期在F线地铁里被挤45分钟吗？他们是在怀念高速公路上走走停停的车流吗？在雨中？不，他们一点也不怀念这些。
What they miss is some sort of transition period. And you can make that transition period in your life, really can, but it's there. And it can be going on a walk. It can be doing the crossword puzzle. It can be meditating or doing yoga. Like there's so many different things depending on your personality that can function
他们怀念的是某种过渡期。你确实可以在生活中创造这种过渡期，真的可以，它就在那里。它可以是去散步。可以是做填字游戏。可以是冥想或做瑜伽。根据你的性格，有太多不同的事情可以发挥
as this sort of buffer space. Yeah, I want to ask you about the physical consequences as well, because I'm talking to you today for my kitchen. I'm sitting on a kitchen chair. I can't imagine that's good for my back Like a lot of remote workers. I have an invested in you know an era on chair or an ergonomic office chair Which can be pretty expensive and take up a lot of space as anybody been talking about this kind of physical consequence of people working from home and not having access to good office furniture. Yeah, and this is a really interesting question for companies that get rid of their leases, right?
这种缓冲空间的作用。是的，我还想问你关于身体健康方面的后果，因为我今天是在厨房里和你对话。我正坐在一把厨房椅子上。我猜这对我的脊椎肯定不好。就像很多远程工作者一样，我没有投资购买一把Aeron椅子或符合人体工程学的办公椅，这些椅子相当昂贵而且占地方。有没有人在讨论人们因为居家办公、无法使用好的办公家具而产生的这种身体健康后果？是的，对于那些退掉办公室租约的公司来说，这是一个非常有趣的问题，对吧？
Are they going to take that money that they spend on the office and that they just going to put that towards their bottom line? Or are they going to say, we're going to take a chunk of this money and we're going to direct it towards our employees to outfit their home offices. Now, in my situation, I have a really small home. I don't have a place for an Aeron chair unless I wanted to put it at my kitchen table. Do you know what I mean? It would be a little bit of truce to have an Aeron chair at my kitchen table. So it's something I've been thinking about in terms of, and I think a lot of people who live in smaller spaces have been thinking about this as well,
他们会把花在办公室上的那些钱收进自己的腰包吗？还是会说，我们要拿出这笔钱的一部分，直接发给员工用来装修他们的家庭办公室？就我目前的情况而言，我的家非常小。我根本放不下一把Aeron椅子，除非我想把它塞在餐桌旁。你懂我的意思吗？把一把Aeron椅子放在餐桌旁会显得有点格格不入。所以我在考虑空间问题时一直在想这个，而且我想很多住在较小空间里的人也一直在考虑这个问题，
like what are our solutions? And this is where I'm reminded of the fact that like working in a flexible style does not mean forever working in your own space. And this is what I say to people who say, I'm so lonely working from home as well, is that this is not the future, right? The future is not working
我们的解决方案是什么？这让我想起了一个事实：采用灵活的工作方式并不意味着永远在自己的空间里工作。这也是我对那些抱怨“在家工作太孤独”的人说的话，这并不是未来，对吧？未来不是在
during a pandemic where you can't be around other people or where it's not as safe to be around other people. The future is going to be tons and tons of co-working spaces that will have good chairs that won't hurt our backs. It'll be working at other people's homes. It will be working at libraries and coffee shops like there'll be all sorts of configurations that we can think of. But that, I think, is the biggest thing to remember that whatever we're doing now is not what we have to be doing in the near future. I mean, it feels like there is a lot of promise
无法与他人接触、或者与其他人在一块儿不够安全的大流行期间工作。未来将会有大量的好椅子、不会伤害我们脊椎的联合办公空间。它会是在别人家里工作。它会是在图书馆和咖啡馆里工作，我们能想到的配置会有各种各样。但我想，最重要的一点是要记住，我们现在所做的事情，并不一定是我们近未来必须要做的事情。我的意思是，感觉有很多希望
to remote work for improving work life for a lot of people, but something we're also seeing is this divide between the people who can work remotely and the people who have to physically go in for their job, like high school teachers and people who work in hospitals and, you know, most of the people in the workforce actually, do you think that divide has grown worse during the pandemic and where do you think that's going? It's a really important question. I think that we are slowly figuring out which jobs do demand presence. There are some companies that I think are forcing people to go into the office for very
远程工作能够改善很多人的工作与生活，但我们同时也看到了这种鸿沟：能够远程工作的人与那些必须亲自去上班的人之间的鸿沟，比如高中老师和医院工作人员，你知道的，实际上是劳动力队伍中的大多数人。你认为这种鸿沟在疫情期间恶化了吗？你认为这种情况未来会走向何方？这是一个非常重要的问题。我认为我们正在慢慢弄清楚哪些工作确实需要实体在场。我认为有些公司之所以强迫人们去办公室，是出于非常
hierarchical reasons. A lot of law firms during the height of the pandemic, all the lawyers stayed at home, but they made paralegals go into the office, right? And that is just hierarchy in place. That is just trying to say, we can control where you go. And we think that you probably do better work if you were in an office,
等级森严的原因。大流行最严重的时候，许多律师事务所的律师都在家办公，但他们却强迫律所助理去办公室，对吧？这正是等级制度的体现。这只是想说，我们可以控制你们去哪里。而且我们认为，如果你在办公室里，你可能会做得更好，
but it has little connection to the necessity to be in an office. So that's part of the question is that I do think that there are some jobs that need to be reconsidered in terms of presence. But when we think more largely about what we generally consider essential workers, which are people who had to go into the office or into a workspace every day,
但这与必须在办公室办公的必要性几乎没有什么关系。所以问题的一部分在于，我认为确实有一些工作需要根据在场的需求重新评估。但当我们更广泛地思考我们通常认为的“核心员工”时，也就是那些每天必须去办公室或工作场所的人，
the last few years is evidence that we've treated them as inessential and disposable in so many different ways. And this is true of whether someone's a healthcare worker or a teacher. And I think a lot of those workers are incredibly rightfully frustrated with people who have no understanding of this sort of risk that they undertook every single day in order to continue to make society function.
过去几年表明，我们在许多不同的方面将他们视作非必要人员和用完即弃的人。无论是医护人员还是老师，情况都是如此。我认为其中许多员工对那些根本不理解他们每天为了维持社会运转而承担的风险的人感到无比愤怒，这是完全合情合理的。
And moving forward, unless we address some of these things, I think that we have to start thinking about these questions in terms of actually demonstrating that the work that essential workers do is essential. And this means pay, this means support, this means paid sick leave, like all sorts of different components that make it more possible and sustainable for people doing this work to keep doing it. Otherwise, we're going to see the continued mass resignation from a lot of these fields where people feel continuously undervalued in their day-to-day jobs. And thank you so much for talking to us. Thank you so much. 99% invisible was produced this week by Chris Barouba,
展望未来，除非我们解决这些问题，否则我们必须开始从“切实证明核心员工的工作至关重要”的角度来思考这些问题。这意味着薪酬，这意味着支持，这意味着带薪病假，这意味着各种不同的组成部分，使得从事这项工作的人更有可能并且可持续地坚持下去。否则，我们将看到许多领域继续出现大规模辞职潮，因为人们在日常工作中不断感到自己的价值被低估。非常感谢你接受我们的采访。非常感谢。99%隐形节目本周由克里斯·巴鲁巴（Chris Barouba）制作，
edited by our executive producer Delaney Hall, music by Swan Rihau, sound mix by Amita Kanatra, fact-checking by Frances Carr Jr. Kurt Goldstedt is our digital director at the rest of the team, includes Vivian Le, Joe Rosenberg, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Lashemba Dawn, Jason DeLeone, Bartine Gonzalez, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Mark Groother at the Henry Ford Museum, Amy Osherman, for providing access to the Herman Miller archives into all the 99 P.I. listeners who spoke to
我们的执行制作人德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）剪辑，音乐由天鹅里豪（Swan Rihau）创作，混音由阿米塔·卡纳特拉（Amita Kanatra）完成，事实核查由小弗朗西斯·卡尔（Frances Carr Jr.）负责。库尔特·戈尔德斯特（Kurt Goldstedt）是我们的数字总监，团队其他成员包括维维安·勒（Vivian Le）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、拉谢巴·道恩（Lashemba Dawn）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeone）、巴蒂恩·冈萨雷斯（Bartine Gonzalez）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker），以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。本周特别感谢亨利·福特博物馆的马克·格鲁瑟（Mark Groother）、为我们提供赫尔曼·米勒档案查阅权限的艾米·奥舍曼（Amy Osherman），以及所有与我们交谈过的99PI听众
us about their experiences with the office. It really helped us shape this story. Thank you so much. We are part of the Stitcher & Serious XM Podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99piorg, where I'm Instagram and Reddit
聊聊他们对办公室的体验。这确实帮助我们塑造了这个故事。非常感谢。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一部分。现在总部设在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的上城区，潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上@Roman Mars，也可以在节目官方账号@99piorg上找到我，我在Instagram和Reddit上也
too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99pi at 99pi.org. Thanks again to the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation for their underwriting support of this special episode. Keep an eye out for each episode in this four-part series, The Future of Data-Data. The next one we'll be looking at broadband communication as an essential public utility. All the episodes will be appearing in the 99pI feed over the next few months.
活跃着。你可以在99pi.org上找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及99pi的每一期往期节目。再次感谢罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会对本期特别节目的赞助支持。请关注这个四部分系列节目中的每一期，即“数据的未来”。下一期我们将探讨宽带通信作为一种基本的公共公用事业。在接下来的几个月里，所有节目都将陆续出现在99pi的动态中。
If you like thinking about the future of things and have a hunch about what it will take to build an equitable future, share it at shareyourhunch.org. I'm submitting my own hunch that comes to me from all the years of doing the Con Law podcast with Elizabeth Jo, so I'm going to share your hunch.org and selecting the prompt. I have a hunch. I have a hunch that different states in the U.S US will continue to diverge when it comes to basic rights, and the notion of federalism and state sovereignty will become more and more hallmark of political progressives.
如果你喜欢思考事物的未来，并且对于建设一个公平的未来需要什么有自己的直觉，请在shareyourhunch.org上分享它。我要分享我自己的直觉，这来自于我与伊丽莎白·乔（Elizabeth Jo）多年来一起做《宪法法律》（Con Law）播客的经历，所以我将访问shareyourhunch.org并选择提示。我有一种直觉。我有一种直觉，即美国各州在基本权利方面将继续产生分歧，联邦制和州主权的概念将越来越成为政治进步主义的标志。
That's kind of a heavy one, but you know, it's what's been on my mind. Check out other hunches and submit your own hunch at shareyourhunch.org. Dolly, please forgive me for what I'm about to do. Stitch your serious axiom, what a way to make a living! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这听起来有点沉重，但你知道的，这就是我一直在思考的事情。快去shareyourhunch.org查看其他人的直觉并提交你自己的直觉吧。多莉，请原谅我要做的事情。Stitcher和SiriusXM，谋生真是不容易啊！本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。